Hey everyone! Today we're learning English
with the biggest hits from Maroon 5.
By the way, in case you're new here,
we help you to learn fast English
without getting lost, without missing the jokes
and without subtitles. Just like Luke who says
that he passed his C1 Advanced English Exam
thanks to our lessons. So be sure to hit that
subscribe button and the bell down below so
that you don't miss any of our new lessons.
If you struggle to understand fast speaking
natives then I highly recommend our Fluent
with Friends course. In this 48 week course you
will learn with the first two seasons of Friends,
you'll receive pdf power lessons every
week, vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle Global Community and
so much more. And the best part is you can try it
right now for free with our 3-Part Masterclass.
All you have to do is click up here or down in
the description box below to learn more and sign
up now. We look forward to seeing you there.
If you're a fan of learning English
with songs then I highly recommend
you check out this playlist where you'll
find a great variety of lessons. You can
click up here or down in the description
box below to choose your next lesson.